E
HE KILLED 17 PEOPLE, AND NOW
FACE THE DEATH PENALTY.
OUR GUEST IS OUT FRONT.
>> THE 1200 BUILDING HAS
HAUNTED THE MARJORY STONEMAN
DOUGLAS COMMUNITY FOR FOUR
YEARS, A CRIME SCENE LEFT
UNTOUCHED SINCE FEBRUARY 2018
WITH THIS DAY.
THE DAY JURORS WOULD WALK
THROUGH WHAT REMAINS AFTER THE
HORROR UNFOLDED WITHIN THOSE
WALLS.
AFTER SURVIVORS ESCAPED THE
BLOODSTAINS, THE SHATTERED
GLASS, VALENTINE'S DAY GIFTS,
EVEN RANDOM SHOES WERE LEFT
BEHIND.
TODAY, JUROR SAAD ALL.
>> I KEPT THINKING ABOUT THESE
KIDS THAT SHOULD NOT BE
EXPERIENCING THIS.
FORMER TEACHER, IV, REMEMBERS
WHAT SHE LEFT IN ROOM 12:14
THAT VALENTINE'S DAY.
>> THERE IS A BOX OF VALENTINES
CHOCOLATES SITTING ON MY DESK,
WITH PUPPIES ON, A STUDENT
BROUGHT ME.
>> THE JURY WILL HAVE TO DECIDE
IF CRUZ GETS THE DEATH PENALTY
OR LIFE IN PRISON AFTER
PLEADING GUILTY TO 17 MURDERS
AND 17 ATTEMPTED MURDERS.
>> IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TELL THE JURY
ABOUT YOUR DAD?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> I MISS HIM.
>> FAR MORE DAMAGE LEFT BEHIND
FOR LOVED ONES, AGONY AND
EMPTINESS THAT WILL NEVER GO
AWAY, STRAINS ON RELATIONSHIPS.
>> WE HAVE A VOID IN OUR LIVES
THAT WILL NEVER BE FULL.
>> FOR DAYS, LOVED ONES TOLD --
>> HELENA WAS MURDERED ON HER
FATHER'S BIRTHDAY.
TO TRY TO ARTICULATE HOW THAT
HAS AFFECTED ME WOULD BE TO RIP
MY HEART OUT AND PRESENTED TO
YOU SHATTERED IN 1 MILLION
PIECES.
>> TESTIMONY THAT BROUGHT EVEN
THE SHOOTER'S DEFENSE TEAM TO
TEARS.
THIS ALL COMES AFTER WEEKS OF
THE PROSECUTION MAKING THE CASE
THAT THIS WAS A METHODICAL AND
CALCULATED SCHOOL SHOOTING.
PROSECUTORS SHOWED THE JURY
SOCIAL MEDIA POST BY THE JURIES,
MONTHS BEFORE THE MASSACRE
STRUCK, QUOTE, I'M GOING TO BE
A PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER,
IN MULTIPLE POSTS, EXPRESSING
HATRED.
>> JUST WANT TO KILL PEOPLE --
>> THERE WERE ALSO INTERNET
SEARCHES INCLUDING ONE FOR,
QUOTE, GOOD SONGS TO PLAY WHILE
KILLING PEOPLE.
REVELATIONS AT THE COURT AND AT
THE CRIME SCENE THAT EXPLAIN TO
THE JURY WHAT LED UP TO THE
MASSACRE THAT FOREVER CHANGED A
SCHOOL AND SHATTERED LIVES IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
>> JUST BEING ABLE TO SAY THE
TRUTH OF WHAT HAPPENED, IN
FRONT OF THE SHOOTER, THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN.
MOST OF THESE MASS SHOOTERS
DON'T SURVIVE THE SHOOTINGS.
I'M SORRY TO SAY I REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY SYMPATHY FOR HIM.
I REALLY DON'T.
I DON'T HATE.
I DON'T HATE ANYONE.
BUT HE DESERVES WHATEVER HE IS
GOING TO GET.
>> AND SEAMUS, THE TEACHER AT
THE END THERE, WHO IS TEACHING
HOLOCAUST LESSONS THAT DAY
BEFORE SHE HAD TO RUSH OUT.
JURORS WHO WENT INTO HER
CLASSROOM LIKELY SAW WITH A
SMALL GROUP OF REPORTERS SAW
TODAY, A BLOODSTAINED BOOK
CALLED, TELL THEM YOU REMEMBER.
OR EVEN THE LEARNING OBJECTIVE
THAT IS STILL ON T